[Music]
this is a terrible strategy and I'm
surprised this probably Ben Affleck
character wasn't shot as soon as he
opened the door yeah the light is coming
in but still anyone inside could see and
shoot this mother Claire instantly bad
strategy we'll get back to the scene
later but now let's go back even further
in time to when Christian was a kid we
just wanted you to know that you didn't
sit down in an auditorium playing a
boring movie about autism there's guns
and death in this movie baby suck it
first of all 20 miles south of Chicago
is way more specific than I'm guessing
we need but good job on detailed movie
Ted sir
approximately 200 make it 300 squares
everyone pretends it's more legal or
legal at all for this guy to say his
wife's office is actually 300 square
feet if Christian doesn't actually say
anything I just have one over to the
bead store yep I'd ride the truck the
company truck movie artfully
communicates to me that this is a good
guy because he helps this random old
couple cheat on their taxes everyone
knows the IRS is the bad guy so he's Bob
Parr basically at this point lying on a
federal employment application is a
felony and what is blackmailing
employees could do shady non-legal fish
I got a two-way kerf on that is just
thick with catfish and basses
sure why exactly does Christian offer up
the fact that he shoots he doesn't
really want to hang out with this couple
at their house does he but that's
exactly what happens when he finds out
he can shoot at their place in every
single one of these photographs
Christian spaces either obscured or
turned away from the camera now yeah
there knows exactly where the
surveillance photos are taken which I'm
going to say is bull or the people
taking the photos are awful at their job
you mean there was never a shot where
they could get its face an accountant or
accountant the accountant I wonder what
we should call this movie I retire in
seven months so let me get this straight
you've been looking for someone within
your department you could blackmail to
spend all their time on the accountant
and seven months before you retire you
finally find somebody chief what luck
also I imagine you spend so much time on
this you could have diverted those
resources to finding the account
yourself but you're right this blackmail
thing is a way better plan don't doubt
that he's got all this timed out and
everything but what the batteries on the
garage door opener aren't working
properly when he presses this button
he's crashing through his garage door
that's what he's adjusting his plate
like an OCD person but the most serious
problem on display here is that there
was no beverage on this table how he
planning to wash down that brick 50
goodness
[Music]
this is probably very comforting to
Christian somehow for all epilepsy
sufferers though too bad they can't
watch the movie anymore
watch back features a lot of moms
screaming also this is clearly not a
roland emmerich film since the bad
parent here is the mom and not the dad
why do I feel like the younger brother
could easily grow up to be a
supervillain just based on all the
special attention his autistic brother
gets I mean he's just holy is that a
space heater
that's dangerous turn it off turn it off
yeah better take another that is Olaf
well picked that to order dude it's
scheduled no what the fuck do I care he
had a nightmare he took a pill that
alone is cliche enough for me to send
this moment American sniper the Boston
Edition must be what a mile out not
online best way to be inconspicuous to
counting through assassins on the side
also he's clearly just out in some
Midwestern field did he bribe all the
neighbors within a two-mile radius to
keep quiet about the obvious sniper
rifle sound it's almost like Affleck
said write me my own Jason Bourne movie
damn it he made this article his name is
Robert Paulson
his name is Robert Paulson you were
recommended by Manzarek onyx he told my
brother Lamar that you were nothing
short of supernatural gotta ask if Lamar
is the real bad guy in this movie why
would he hire an accountant that is this
awesome to figure out who's stealing the
money don't you think he would say don't
worry about it I've got an accountant
who's great and then pay off a guy who
won't find anything and seem to be
typing something but it's certainly not
Lou because her fingers never touched to
you on this keyboard what's worse that
she forgot to filter by Case Files or
that doing so leads to another montage
of photos where Affleck omnipotent Lee
avoided having his face on camera in
case you confused it with zero Arizona
well do you think you are you know I am
instead of being super scared of some
asshole calmly getting into his car like
it's no big deal
this dude spins the wheel of things you
wouldn't say to a stranger who was
entering your car unannounced John thank
you a big man doesn't Jesus this guy
just trying to set Brax up to show how
much of a badass he actually is or is he
actually the dumbest person who's ever
lived till he goes over one quarter of
its length before even trying to Anna
Kendrick also can audio file here
instead of the ravenite was bugged you
know for the convenience of the store
this bug apparently did nothing could
take down the Gambino crime family in
the first place even though it was
located in their headquarters I thought
because dogs would never bet on things
in Congress yeah numbers finances
accounting math dance just like after
nearly 20 years Affleck suddenly got
super jealous of Matt Damon's Good Will
Hunting character and demanded a movie
where he also gets to play a trouble
genius
combined with the badass assassin
character Damon also played in other
movies now damn it thank God a flex
autism calming Tramp from when he was a
kid still works when he's an adult and
that this chick has sophisticated enough
audio equipment to detect him saying it
the only way she's gotta collect and
that policy yet is if we at the
appearance of an accident and hopefully
his wife doesn't hear you assholes
talking pretty loudly downstairs but
what fuck ever I'll come back no no come
in dear this universe keeps forcing
Affleck and Kendrick together and it's
getting a little annoying actually she
wanders up as he's getting fired then
lift out insist she still come into the
room then he leaves so why did he tell
Anna Kendrick to come in here then does
he know there's a budding romance
between her and a flick maybe don't buy
such a huge goddamn vehicle no matter
your medication this kind of behavior is
always a bad idea at best you'll be
swallowing floor pills the next few
weeks
at worst you start doing worse than
beating and rolling your own chips
Christian's dad somehow has the
connections and money for private
martial arts lessons first son's also
the Moody is making you wonder so hard
where the brother went that you're now
pretty sure it's the guy that's been
sneaking into these rich guys cars and
houses and that somehow the two brothers
are going to end up facing off by the
end of this movie which is unbelievable
and I'm done tamales another day they
have done that best even the guy beating
to sit out of these two kids thinks they
should stop but world's worst father
over here is going for a record
so the beating show continued called the
book keeper so the bad guys hired by
John Lithgow are going around killing
all the people who could expose him for
stealing all that money so why did it
lead them to this couple pounds of all
places did they go to Christians
accounting offices secretary said he's
not here right now he goes to this old
couples house in the middle of nowhere
to shoot melons though here's the
address
luckily for Christian he shoots with a
high-powered rifle that can hit targets
from a mile away
not when you see you in rich businessman
hire you to kill fools they give you the
targets personalized key cards because
that would somehow never be traced back
to the company this card proudly
displays
Christian leaves this innocent couple
with two dead bodies on their farm with
absolutely no insight into what they're
supposed to say or do about it also
after killing the guy only has Dina's
key card in its pocket why do you assume
she's
imminent danger the guy with the carcass
pocket is the guy who was going to kill
her right I mean yeah you should still
water and all that
I assume this dire even if it's assumed
that other assassins might be taking her
out why would the bearded guy have
Dana's keycard here is a movie that
knows it's showing you the full of
Chicago skyline awesomeness you don't
need a Chicago Illinois USA text clue to
know where you are I'll remove us in for
schooling the Bourne movies on place
names even though this movie still has
its own city labeling issues elsewhere I
realize he's racing to save a girl's
life but driving like this in metro area
Chicago will get you pulled over or shot
thereby keeping you from saving anyone's
life but the bad guy kills her in the
elevator I mean yeah he doesn't for some
reason but what if he does I don't know
why these two assassins disguised as
delivery guys need two extra security
people watching the hallway but good for
them taking this murder seriously unlike
the two guys at the farm did these
delivery guys are apparently hired to
kill Dana which is patently ridiculous
very conveniently Brax who is most
definitely Christian's brother hasn't
been part of either of these two
assassination attempts she was like they
could have led with the gun in the first
place rather than trying to tackle her
and wrestle with her like they did at
the beginning of this now maybe they
were trying to make this seem like a
disappearance no gunshots no witnesses
hearing gunshots but this guy just blew
that all to hell and these dudes don't
get silencers for their guns one pound
home to Meadow Lane since whenever you
decided to take up cooking vacation
during this very important job casual
glimpse at a comic and baseball card
collection that would make Kevin Smith
jizz his pants is casual he actually
adds an Action Comics number one issue
to his travel bag which suggests he
knows a last-minute late-night black
market comics buyer or he's going to
light a cigar with it a lock rusty but
my main concern is the utter and
complete lack of protective casing this
comic is about to be transported in
every crack tear or crease is going to
decrease the value by thousands no
self-respecting Comics collector would
ever transport this issue so had hazard
late this is names of the 100 most
famous mathematician got to ask if
you're going through all this trouble to
change your identity everywhere you go
why would you use an alias on your tax
returns that could match up with any of
those identities if you change your
identity why wouldn't you just go with
Paul Smith for your tax returns and go
with all the famous math guys for your
other ventures what's in it for me
you're already here dude you've got up
in the middle of the night put on
clothes and came down here to computer
search for this lady what's in it for
you is to keep doing what you've been
doing and shut up Jesus you're a greedy
you'd have asked this before ever coming
down here in the first place
who do you
No how did my father was an officer in
the army psychological operations oh
well that is was everything Thanks in
this in 34 homes 17 units daddy was a
check belt or two I'm guessing okay the
need for fill north Matt Club and a
little big not for Ruby expects me to
believe this guy who was definitely
sheltered and had a weird upbringing but
loves mathematics has never heard of a
math club president I just wanted to
walk into the gym and have everybody say
wow so how is it not about the dress but
why would she hire you in the first
place if she thought you and figure it
out
good question but we know Rita's not the
bad guy here it's her brother Lamar now
Rita may have done the hiring but it was
Lamar who got the recommendation the
question really boils down to why would
Lamar suggest an accountant like this to
Rita for her to hire an Anna Kendrick
once again would be amazing in cinema
sense and we'd hire her in an instant
then gets out of the truck to follow
this guy rather unfortunately since yeah
this is the guy trying to find and kill
you but also your behavior here will
cause him to realize you're following it
and give him a huge advantage in
tracking and firing it was there any
good reason to kill read it in this
plant demean Lamar was going to kill the
top two executives an employee who
discovered the missing money and the
accountant he hired to find the missing
money and he'd be miraculously unharmed
what was killing Rita do exactly I mean
I guess more money for him but killing
her means even more suspicion headed his
way zze accounting because Christians
accounting business has a somewhat
unusual name this is going to somehow
open the door for Mary Beth to
investigate him further despite the fact
that his tax return showed he made 75
grand last year I can guarantee other
accountants with other mathematician
names had unusual business names but
this or on hell let's look deeper into
that Museum it's not exactly a smart
Yellowpages because everyone uses the
goddamn yellow pages these days for
business disability because in this
world everyone's still living in 1994
sound of a chance for Kings nails lavash
wait Plainfield that is some amazing
intuition by simply looking at a Google
image of this guy's office I ran another
two hundred and eighty-seven thousand
seven hundred sixty-five dollars to
Kim's nails
445,000 112 dollars through great
Mandarin Chinese five hundred five
thousand nine hundred nine dollars to
Paul's laundromat and somehow this very
smart guy with numbers who covers his
tracks tied all of these to the same
exact accounting firm and reported
ridiculous impossible earnings through
those businesses okay an accident
I don't know what the order is on all
this but I'm assuming it's chronological
we've been told they moved around a lot
but they both look the exact same all
the way through this from the beginning
of the movie to the time their mom left
at the point where they were fighting in
Indonesia - now where they're in France
I mean at some point you grow right
worst father ever
she ditches the girl he's protecting in
fact the girl who he came back to save
which put his ass on the line in the
first place
risk it all the favor one day later did
your ass this movie's protagonist is
making it pretty hard to root for Neil I
recommended you lead the country you
decline he's an accountant yeah as I'm
sure you heard he's also a badass who
took out six of the dude you hired to
kill him so I don't know why you're
stuck on the accountant part of this
equation huh so you're telling me that
Ray was there the day that Christian
shot all those gangsters why did Mary
Beth have to go through all the trouble
of talking to Homeland Security to get a
face match for the surveillance video
that yeah I've been a good dad I'm a
lousy agent and I've been a weak man but
that I didn't screw up hahaha
yes you did over 18 minutes of super
expositional backstory will snap when
after the guard
escaped from a third floor window so
without any kind of escape plan
Christian purely improvising escaped
prison police report names wolf soldier
1 widower identified the colonel by name
I checked it's an alias so the widower
didn't know the real name of his wife's
ex-husband or kids but knew who her
ex-husband was by sight tell me I'm
retiring in a few months when she calls
somebody needs to be there answer the
real question is why didn't you tell her
at least some of the sooner main thing
that drives ray King is finding this
accountant not to send Mary Beth to jail
for lying on our application so why not
give her something more than nothing
make small talk what's it matter what
he's having you know this isn't a super
simple movie finding Simpson is actually
pretty hard but the accountant does this
thing I wish movies would stop doing
giving the hero a surprise appearance
from the bad guys perspective I would
have liked to have seen how Christian
snuck up on these guys guarding the
mansion we'd like to see how this guy
actually operates
give me the layout of the home points of
entry corridor rooms
cover why don't you already have that
information surely your secret british
chick who can change your identity and
sell stolen paintings can find some
blueprints to a mansion before you wait
war on it they can trace a guy on comm
so evil dude goes into safe mode and I'm
left wondering why the accountants so
loudly took out a dude in such a way is
to have the evil bosses immediately
checking for him on comms
I mean instead of a loud bullet why not
like this guy in the throat a movie
accidentally bleeds into John wick for
me considering I send both within two
weeks and also this scene is super John
wiki yeah and when the movie gets all
action II it's nearly impossible to
figure out the perspective the layout of
the backyard where Christian is in
relation to the other guys and so forth
it's not underworld or anything but it's
still hard to follow why didn't you have
any guys on the roof in the first place
you had guys outside on the perimeter
and teams who could go out to engage in
a firefight with him but nobody on the
roof team lucky is everyone involved
survives this fault however many martial
arts his father trained him in this
opponent's father trained him and even
more because the accountant be getting
his ass kicked here yo can you survive a
flashbang to the chest if you have a
bulletproof vest on according to this
movie you can he's got panning control
access on this footage and he watched
the entire fight let that guy die just
out of what voyeurism was this guy while
Christian was doing his nursery rhyme a
minute ago god damn that took ages
another movie essentially comes to a
standstill because of this surprise
which I'm not sure is earned or need it
I mean did we even see how much these
brothers meant to each other really
Rex never setup can word during all
those flashbacks there was never really
any moment where we saw them bonding now
this movie is going to take its
sweet-ass time finishing because of the
surprise while these two incredibly
reunited brothers wrestled the apparent
true evil dude just watches on webcam
it's like porn for people who like
sibling beatings also so he heard what
Brax and christian said to each other
right he knows this isn't a good
situation to be in correct why isn't he
leaving why is he watching this movie
with us I hadn't left yet this would be
the not so perfect time to do so but
Lamar probably still thinks this guy is
a lowly accountant brothers got a hug
yeah yeah like a billion to one is my
guess hey you just here to give you a
lecture no need for me to leave which is
what I should have done about five times
already Mayan gods names I ever hire you
so they push your books then I found a
mistake
you wanted to be sure the safe to go
public let's talk about Lamar's plan he
hires an accountant he has to know work
with criminals specializing and hiding
their dirty money despite that being the
chief reason higher the account reports
to his sister and a CFO the people he
doesn't want to know about his
embezzling loan the hole he finds it
reports it to his sister instead of him
and now this becomes a plan where you
have to murder your sister and your best
friend
dreamboat shall we check so Justine was
the computer voice all along and one
question though if this computer is that
super advanced how was she helping
Cristian before this computer was made
she's been helping him for like ten
years right where did she learn her
hacking skills her ability to change
Christians identities
oh hey Anna Kendrick boy she really had
dick all to do in this movie didn't she
well the trailer keys thank you how's
she ever going to explain that if an art
expert comes by her apartment
you know how we do this for me we know a
thing or two because we've seen a thing
or two we are armed
oh Jesus Christ Satan born in a street
no touching policy here but um oh what I
was a week in the hotbox chipper who
doesn't scratch it out all the kind of
Scratchy
I got him right there are no two words
in the English language more harmful
than good job I trust myself I trust my
feelings I'm not going to try to be
anything other than who I am anymore I
hope you can accept that
what kind of for me I have a once asked
what's in it for me
perhaps you're under estimating the
positive effect that your career
transition can have on your children the
positive effect